they weren't really writing Latin
characters the way I experienced it or
saw them in in real life how
three-dimensional and and Brilliant
Latin people are in real life and I just
wasn't seeing that in films so I wanted
to give it the full representation
[Music]
Bros
I play a game boy so I I love my Super
Mario bro I was pretty good at it you
know I'm a little younger than Bob was
at the time so yeah you know it just
makes sense he was like oh I want to ask
her and now I'm playing a video game
Where's My Life going you know I
couldn't understand him really most of
the time unless unless I was drinking
and then I thought I could understand
them
last name Mario okay what's your name
Luigi Luigi Luigi
Luigi Mario
and Luigi Mario I try to give him a
little like you know what kids were
looking like in Brooklyn you know with
the backwards baseball cap close the
little baggie and whatnot like when
everybody was dressing I wanted to
appeal to young kids you know instead of
like two old guys so I was kind of naive
I was in love with the princess and
whatnot and then you know Bob was the
older protective brother
oh not now
what single cell organism did you evolve
from the directors who created Max
heaven and they were the biggest
commercial directors of the era they had
this dark dark vision that Disney was
not okay with so there was all this butt
heading that was incredible I mean that
party scene those are all strippers from
North Carolina
that they put on the set and they had
him like in the most revealing clothes
and costumes and then they had to like
Disney was not happy they had to cut a
lot of it out blow it out CGI with
whatever bad technology they had back in
the day you know but I I love those
directors and I mean they gave me an
opportunity I mean they stuck their neck
out to put a Latin guy as the lead to
play Bob Hoskins brother I mean that was
that was unheard of at the time it was
so Innovative and I was so grateful to
them for that
did you see that what it's trying to
communicate
Luigi it's a mushroom come on to be
honest the movie was not received as
well as we had hoped I mean you always
hoped for the best you don't go into a
movie going boy I can't wait till this
bombs we've all had big hopes for it but
you know it didn't it was the first
video game of its of of the era of all
time that nobody was prepared for that
so I did okay but then kids fell in love
with it and found it you know on on DVD
on VHS and a lot of people come up to me
they go they love it so you know through
their eyes I love it
Carlito's Way
there's something wrong with the check
yeah there's something wrong
with the joke
Benny man
oh oh man oh man I'm
sorry I missed it again I'm sorry I got
no problem no problem see Batman's
awesome they owes me some money and he's
a little slow and paying me so I'm just
working off one you know we have a
former introduce you know my name is
Benny Blanco from the Bronx I'm a Latin
guy and I didn't want to play another
drug dealer I was just kind of sick of
that kind of routine and so I turned it
down three times and then the producer
said look this is the last time I'm
coming to you we're gonna go to Benicio
okay I'll take it
so I took it and then I did a lot of
research I hung out with a lot of drug
dealers in the Les
and and I I was crazy because I thought
I thought I had celebrity immunity and
then I realized nobody's gonna care
about it when they shoot them up one of
the guys I was running with his brother
got shot I'm glad I had left because
yeah I would have got shot too
but I mean all that research paid off
and Brian De Palma let me bring all my
friends in the club scene those are all
my friends and my ex-wife and so that
made it real I felt really comfortable
at home and and I improvised all that
dialogue with Pacino the Palma taught me
how to act on film on this flick he like
let me do I did like 30 takes of my
entrance on film which is unheard of you
did independent film back then you had
to beg for another take and you had to
have a good reason because it was too
expensive and he did 30 takes on my
entrance and I would do crazier things
and he'd laugh I'd knock people's trays
down I'd throw my cigarette at people
and he loved he loved it
second time you tell me down for a drink
man well you don't like my champagne hey
could be
I don't know maybe somebody's
understanding here I don't know man
maybe you don't remember me my name is
maybe I don't remember the last time I
blew my nose either
the are you I shall remember you
what you think you like me
you ain't like me it was a
lot of stuff going on on that set I
think they I think they started to
believe that it was the 70s and so I
started Living that way uh let me see
what what can I talk about
um
there's a couple things I can't talk
about because yeah I can't talk about
that no
no let me see hmm
no I guess I can't talk about a lot of
stuff what do you learned
that yeah let's stay there he is the
most present person I've ever worked
with in my life like some actors you
know come a little prepared they worked
on it a little bit in the mirror and
they fall in love with like the way they
did it he's not like that he's just
right there listening nobody listens
like him I saw how incredible and
relaxed he was I've never seen anybody
be like that
Ice Age
[Music]
they left without me
they do this every year
why doesn't anyone love me
isn't there anyone who cares about Sid
the sloths
all right I'll just go by myself you
know it started out as a drama and I was
the only funny character and it started
out with different actors Ben Stiller
Philip Seymour Hoffman and then because
they wanted to make it funnier than they
got you know Ray Romano and Dennis Leary
and then they made the whole thing funny
took five years to get from point A to
point B and then you know the rest is
history now to find a music
I'm getting her out
but ho a foe come on come on you want to
piss me
off spoils worthy I'm such a number
I studied with Lee Strasburg by my
acting killed him I was at Strasburg
Institute I did a sense memory thing he
was going that that's terrible that's
awful and he died at night but I took a
lot from the method you know and and I
used it for the rest of my life and so
you know I did as much research as I
could because the director Chris wedge
he wanted me to play myself I go I don't
want to play myself I want to create a
character that and a voice that comes
out of that drawing that they showed me
so I I did a ton of voices from like on
a tape back then like 50 voices like I
did Southern Voice just in case they
wanted to be kind of slow because he's a
slow that's why we're gonna do that but
he didn't like that so I said what about
if he's Street y'all what if he's dead
Street you know gangster what not come
on he didn't like that either so then I
did whatever it was a Southeast Asian
accent it was something really cute like
that perhaps no so I say all right so
send me uh Discovery Channel footage so
I saw it and they told they said that
you know the the sloth holds its food
inside its mouth so I put a sandwich in
my mouth and I'm walking around talking
about how many do I come up with this
this character and I was like oh my God
this this is a voice so I called Chris
wedge I go Chris guess who this is she
goes I don't know it's Sid the Sloth I
found myself that's that's how we got
the voice I told you Sid you're not
qualified to run a camp I was since when
do qualifications have anything to do
with child care besides these kids look
after me I'm the role model to them
foreign
I can see that you know obviously I love
this franchise I love that character
he's so lovable I think you have to be
doing what the what the animated
character is doing for the voice to have
that reality and vitality otherwise it
sounds like you're acting so like if if
I if I'm like
falling I'll I'll like hit myself or if
I'm being choked I'll choke myself and
if I'm running out of breath I'll run as
fast as I can for a little bit you can't
do a lot of sounds sometimes because you
you wreck the the recording if you if
you hit something like that so I'll do
it like before the take or after if I'm
drinking water I'll drink some water if
I'm eating I'll get some yeah
[Music]
if you're going to become a drag queen
you're gonna have to learn these things
what do you mean be a drag queen I am a
drag queen oh no no no no you will
simply put a boy in a dress
I I felt like because we were three
straight actors that we had to really
bring a lot of Integrity to these roles
into the storytelling we needed to
represent correctly and we were all all
of us were in you know and we went to
all the escuelita was this huge 42nd
street drag ball Latin and black and
then we went to Sally's and Sally's one
and two all the the famous drag bars uh
of the of the era we had drag queens
that were assigned to us to help us so I
had Larissa Dumont just Puerto Rican
drag queen from the South Bronx and
would work with me and teach me how to
walk teach me how to use my hands and
then I I I went vegetarian vegan for six
months before we shot so I would lose
all my muscle so I become like veal
tender and smooth and then I you know
you know because in my family you know
we have some dark skinned people and you
know there's so much self-hate and and
racism in Latin America a lot of my
Islands have like brown skin but they'll
put on lighter shade makeup and the next
will be like four Shades Darker than
their faces and I always noticed that it
was so odd to me so you know so a parent
of you know the inbred Colonial sort of
self-hate so I did that for Chichi I
made her face a little lighter than her
neck and then at the end she loves her
you know her her Browner skin
I gotta say that Chichi Rodriguez became
an iconic character for lgtbq plus and
trans kids I go everywhere and these
kids come up to me and goes because of
this character in this movie I had the
confidence to come out to my parents so
I felt very honored that I was able to
afford some people some comfort and some
self-confidence I feel like that's when
you do good work that's what you wanted
to do you know that's what you that's
what you hope for that it has an effect
on people and it helps them through hard
times or or or or gives them a
confidence to be who they are you know I
love that
Romeo plus Juliet
[Music]
it was between me and Benicio del Toro
and baz was like you know John you he he
mumbles and you don't that's why you got
the part that was the only reason
because you know Benicio is the bomb and
then we had two week rehearsal that was
intense man it was so intense but it was
worth it it was so we all became a crew
we were really up for each other I mean
Leo was amazing man a lot of actors get
I don't know they get a little privilegy
and they don't show up really for your
off camera you know or just read it he
would give the same performance that he
just gave in front of the camera he
would give for you behind the camera
that's how generous an actor he is it's
so good Capulet whose name I Tender Is
dearly as my own
satisfied
be satisfied
well you know it's the same language I
mean baz use the same language the only
thing he did was uh trim it a little bit
down you know which they've done before
with the zepparelli version It's the
exact same language except put in a
modern setting and we shot in Mexico
it's like he made it sort of like uh
street gangs you know like
semi-futuristic not too far in the
future kind of street gangs and it's the
capulets where like a Latin
family sort of my cruise all Latin but
our parents are all Italian people
playing Latin people as you know as
Hollywood does but they were great I
mean Paul cervino and Diane Vernor are
fantastic I mean they're brilliant I
mean she's the best Lady Capulet I've
ever seen because you never remember
that character it's always like a blur
but she made it stand out that's how
brilliant she is
[Music]
even more difficult bass called me up he
said I want you to be this sleeping
Argentinian and I was like sleeping you
called the narcoleptic Argentinian and I
was like that doesn't sound like what if
I gotta be like this
through the whole entire movie it didn't
sound like it was going to be good so I
was like I want to be to lose the track
he goes but I already got uh Rowan
Atkinson let's go let me let me just saw
I went to Chateau Marmont auditioned for
four hours on my knees now with the list
Johnson I would talk like this with the
lift and then now the British accents I
did it with the British accent for the
longest time and and I got the part
[Music]
now you're in
the world
oh my God it was it was a a month or
four weeks rehearsal we had dialect
coaches we had dance coaches
we had movement coaches we had
everything kind of coaches you know I
read all the biographies I looked at all
the photographs and baz let me write
there's a scene between me and you and
McGregor that I took from from
toulouse's letters and I created this
scene in bads that's how collaborative
baz is
on
Chuckles with their freaking dumb noses
in this lousy body hat
I don't mind being short fat and ugly
for the pay sucks
the comic book industry was failing in
the 80s Todd McFarland created Venom and
then he created Spawn and he brought
Darkness edginess death vulgarity nobody
was doing that and we revolutionized the
whole comic book industry it was a big
deal it was the first black superhero so
everybody was excited by it
you can't kill him
[Music]
oh
well the first day was eight hours but
they got it down to four hours so I
would get up at three a.m start makeup
at four am be done by 8 A.M and then go
on set and it took like about an hour
and a half to take the makeup off but it
was old school too it was old school
techniques there was no coolant coming
through I was sweat I would drip soaking
wet you could ring the costume out so I
had to constantly remind myself to
hydrate and uh the brakes you know the
whole thing was glued to my face so I
couldn't take it off for lunch and I had
these big teeth giant eye contacts it
would make you lose your mind some
sometimes but it was worth a while
because because I was so
miserable that it added to the
characters edginess and Mark to pay the
director was was so fun to work with so
loose so chilly let me ad-lib all this
madness and the edgier ad-libs are in
the director's cut
Summer of Sam
police said that the handwritten letter
addressed to Mr President contained a
numerous occult symbols were signed by
the madman himself calling himself the
Son of Sam my favorite movie of all
summer Sans my favorite the best of my
work you know spike is an actor's
director you know and he really knows
how to create the proper environment
they're not borrowed a lot from him when
I directed my films I remember exactly
what he said you know so he made us hang
out and he told us you've got to spend
time together to create this Bond it's
not going to happen if you just show up
on set so we all started having lunches
together breakfast and then we did a
week's rehearsal and then we we
continued that on the set you know it
was it was it was a it was amazing
Adrian Brody had just come from Thin Red
Line where he was the lead
and as they were shooting
[Music]
they had he had given all his lines
enrolled to Jim caviezio so by the end
of the shoot Adrian was an extra in the
movie he just shot so he came with that
edginess to the set but he was he's so
brilliant I think he's the best thing in
the whole movie
if you walk out that door I'm gonna
jump I don't want to kill myself
everything my life and I ain't
got I got friends I ain't got
nothing maybe I suck at everything I do
the only thing I have and I
can't live with oh my God we you know I
punched the glass I cut myself she was
really weeping and crying and it Spike
creates this safe environment and he
loves like raw acting he wants you to go
as raw as you can and he would like pump
his fist when he when I was killing it
behind the cameras I would go even
harder at it and we went to can with it
so that was really exciting for me it
was the first time I'd ever been to camp
John Wick
the owner of the card
you kill him or what
no you sure as hell up his dog he
up his dog that's what you did
you up his dog
that's crazy man
oh look at you Aurelio yeah everyone's a
card Chop Shop you know where you break
up cars and you put them together and
and I'm an expert engine maker that's
that's what John Wick gets it's so
interesting because when I got the John
Wick script it was okay it wasn't like
wow I can't wait to do this it was like
is it interesting you know you didn't
know what it was going to be then I go
to the premiere and I was like what
it it was so visceral you didn't see it
on the page it was so David Leach did an
amazing job I mean he's such a he David
Leach and Chad were kano's son
coordinators for um uh all the uh Matrix
300 uh they did a lot of stuff for them
so he trusted them and he gave him that
opportunity to to jump from being some
coordinators to being directors and
Alfie Allen plays a little Russian Punk
that I get to knock out it was so much
fun to do that flick you're gonna come
into my shop and you're gonna pull a gun
on me that's great man come on neither
you kill me right now when you get the
out of my shop
that was a blast I I had so much fun I
love knocking people out better than
being knocked out
the power
no
are you okay I'm okay
what the hell is that
I don't know
um like a static shock or something
the power is this beloved novel by now
Naomi Alderman it's kind of like sci-fi
but much more realistic much more
organic and believable like you can't
jump to shark you can't go it doesn't go
into magic and it's young women when
they reach adolescence because of
evolution and because of the need to
protect themselves in the world grow a
new organ and the organ like like the
brain like the eye gives off an
electrical charge but if they can focus
and learn how to use it it can make it
like a nuclear blast so now they have
this whole power and the world doesn't
know what to do with them they don't
know how to use it things start to go
awry things start to go crazy in the
world and then the women start spreading
it and they start bringing it to the
older women and all the women get it and
and non-binary people get it and then
you know what he said to me no what
he told me to not get my panties in a
bunch
I don't like him talking about my wife's
panties like that you want to kick his
ass wait wait you didn't I wish I could
have taken him oh I know you could I
know you could my character Rob I'm a
scientist but I'm also The Man Behind
the powerful woman you know I'm kind of
a stay-at-home dad Mr Mom even though
I'm a scientist she has the career the
bigger career and I have to take a back
seat so it's like reversal of rolls The
Producers were all women the directors
are all women the writers were all women
the leads were all women it was an
amazing time I I I felt very nurtured
and I felt very comfortable and safe it
was great